Ron please no no way come on Ron I've
been a loyal foot soldier give me my
shot let me have lot 48 is that a travel
pillow around your neck Ron I don't know
how to explain this to you when you've
been down in the pit have you been in
the pit no I haven't gotten down there
yet why I have when you fill in when I
visited the bottom of the pit on a
fact-finding mission and when you're
down there you get some perspective
about what it all means let me tell you
something Ron what it means is I want
this subcommittee I've been quite open
about this around the office I don't
want this parks department to build any
parks because I don't believe in
government I think that all government
is a waste of taxpayer money my dream is
to have the park system privatized and
run entirely for profit by corporations
like Chuckie Cheese they have an
impeccable business model I would rather
work for Chuckie Cheese Ron Swanson it
is my pleasure to inform you that you
are a finalist for the job of assistant
city manager Chris I feel I should
remind you that I do not believe that
the position or the entire government
should exist that said you'd be a fool
not to pick me I will walk deeper into
the belly of the beast if it means I'm
able to further limit reckless
government spending I mean I have so
many ideas some are simple like take
down traffic lights and eliminate the
post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like bring all of this crumbling
to the ground so after all that it's
really not that bad you're gonna get a
letter in your file Ron I just wanted to
say thank don't worry about it
no I didn't I didn't do it for Leslie I
did it because I hate bureaucracy my
idea of a perfect government is one guy
who sits in a small room at a desk and
the only thing he's allowed to decide is
who to nuke the man has chosen based on
some kind of IQ test and maybe also a
physical tournament like a decathlon and
women are brought to him maybe when he
desires that although candy is our bread
and butter we also care about the health
of our customers and that's why we'll be
debuting our new healthy energy bar
nutriyums take a look hi I'm Nick
Newport jr. CEO of sweetums and I'd like
to introduce to you our new line of
energy bars nutriyums
we start with 100% all-natural corn and
we add just a little bit of sweetums
corn syrup will drop a sunshine and some
other stuff and since it from sweetums
you know your kids know well that family
looks like healthy look at them they're
all wearing vests we don't make
nutrients for dogs yet shoelace
nutriyums where nutritious meets tasty
by speeding I could not be happier about
this I think the entire government
should be privatized Chuckie Cheese
could run the parks everything operated
by tokens dropping a token go on the
swing set dropping another token take a
walk
dropping a token look at a duck new tree
hums energy bars are just absolutely
loaded with high-fructose corn syrup and
fatty oils and any way you slice it
they're just extremely unhealthy for you
Leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and I
have a heart attack at 43 you can you
are free to do so to me that's beautiful
I enjoy government function
it's like I enjoy getting kicked in the
Nuggets with a steel-toed move but this
hotel always serves bacon-wrapped shrimp
that's my number one favorite food
wrapped around my number three favorite
food I go to a banquet in honor of those
Somali pirates if they serve
bacon-wrapped shrimp excuse me
hey table 12 can I get a what-what Wow
thank you I mean and you look stunning
but Leslie wow I was going for a while
you got it
I was told it was black tie I like your
hairdo Leslie thank you much it's just
like my brothers he's an officer in the
Air Force bacon-wrapped shrimp oh thanks
I'm okay
I wasn't offering hey am i interrupting
something important impossible I work
for the government I just picked up the
girls thought was stuff fine Diane and I
have been seeing a lot of each other
recently she is a sharp confident strong
woman her children are loud we just
wanted to invite you to come
trick-or-treating
we have to go by 7:00 or else good can
you'll be gone what the hell just
happened
hey bro listen I was trying to buy this
handcrafted mahogany wood model of a
b-25 mitchell Panchito aircraft for me
don't sass me and I went to this website
and this ad popped up that said hey Ron
Swanson check out this great offer
what's your question my question is what
the hell like how do they know who you
are yeah okay um there are these things
called cookies where like if you go to a
site and buy something it'll remember
you and then create ads for other stuff
you might want to buy so it learns
information about me seems like an
invasion of privacy dude if you think
that's bad go to Google Earth and type
in your address
with current and projected deficits we
need to cut expenditures by 32% let's
make it an even 40 oh that's not
necessary slash it
slash it I am an official member of a
task force dedicated to slashing the
city budget just saying that gave me a
semi right off the bat we sell City Hall
let somebody turn it into a large gas
station or at t.j.maxx Ron that is a
very creative idea but we don't want to
sell any of our major assets because we
don't want to lose out on any future
revenue streams
I hear that don't worry I have tons more
ideas okay so sorry new ringtone don't
cut anything without me can I help you
hi my class is here on a field trip and
that's just interview someone for a
school project okay you can wait at that
table and someone will be here some time
but aren't you here now no my reports
due tomorrow what's it on why government
matters really it's never too early to
learn that the government is a greedy
piglet that suckles on a taxpayer's teat
until they have sore chapped nipples I'm
gonna need a different metaphor to give
this nine-year-old what's your name
ma'am Lauren Marcus Lauren my name is
Ron Swanson and I'm gonna tell you
everything you need to know about the
miserable screwed-up world of local
government you must earn your mustache
don't sass me burkas let's get started
this is your lunch now you should be
able to do whatever you want to with
this right you want to eat all of it
great if you want to throw it away in
the garbage that's your prerogative but
here I come the government
and I get to take 40% of your lunch and
that Lauren is how taxes work that's not
fair
you're learning uh-oh capital gains tax
and that Lauren is how FDR ruined this
country Lauren
ready to head back well I guess it's
time for you to head home I've really
enjoyed talking with you you are and
this is not a joke much smarter than
most of the people who work in this
building I like talking with you too mr.
Swanson run hang on hang on I have
something for you this is a claymore
landmine use that to protect your
property thanks Ron
you got it well Diane for potholes you
want to speak with Public Works
I understand you've tried them four
times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while I
transfer you
you